it's people like Juliet who've been at
greater risk of dying from Kovac 19 from
the offset of this pandemic why because
she's black from an ethnic minority just
aged 57 her family said she had the most
infectious smile she was kind caring and
thoughtful it's painful you know his
dependence just too much to beer my late
wife was chamois she was a very looking
woman she was loved
she loved her help orders Juliet's
husband too had coronavirus and now we
know thousands of other black Asian and
minority ethnic people who've succumbed
to this virus face the greatest risk
that's why for weeks we've witnessed a
disproportionate number of deaths within
this vulnerable community figures from
the ONS revealed that people from black
Asian and minority ethnic communities
are more likely to die from Co vid 19
compared to their white counterparts
black women are four point three times
more likely to die than white women and
black men are 4.2 times more likely when
these figures are adjusted for other
factors such as deprivation and
underlying health issues the odds of
someone from Abby AME background dying
from this virus or reduced but black and
South Asian people are still almost
twice as likely to die researchers also
found that while people from B AME
backgrounds are at a higher risk of
death
it is only partly down to underlying
health conditions and deprivation
one factor which could also play a role
is key worker jobs that people from this
community have a lot of people working
in frontline occupations not just in
health work but in supermarkets in
transport all over the place the people
who are getting the most exposure to
kovat are likely to be much more likely
to be from black and minority ethnic
backgrounds it's the first time we've
seen detailed data like this and the
findings are alarming in response to Sky
News the government made it clear
despite after pages of research and
official information they still aren't
prepared to shield this hurting
community will take decisions as a
policy makers when we've got clear
advice from Phe on the causes and the
implications and what we could
responsibly do but Juliet's daughter
wants to see changes what we actually
need to focus on is now what is it that
is causing this I feel like it's highly
social in inequality we need to think of
the jobs that people have we as blacks
as Asians as a community we are put at
risk every single day all along this
issue has been clear and the faces of
those who've lost their lives during
this outbreak show it the real
life-and-death implications of social
inequality are becoming increasingly
apparent but it's taken a global
pandemic and thousands of deaths to
highlight it in the man Rasheed Sky News